what is this big thing the only time I
ever see us use these is like an Home
Depot the only Swedish snacks I've had
are from Christmas stands and then IKEA
the only thing that I know about Sweden
is like swedish fish I know that's very
basic I'm a dual citizen of Sweden in
America and I have family in Sweden and
I've been going back and forth to visit
them most of my life growing up I've
been here for five years my roommate in
college had a lot of candy then brought
home and I want to try it so I'm like
I'm still pretty frustrated I'm
imagining the regular traditional cookie
with some chocolate nothing too spicy
from these Swedish people and those who
suspect we're pretty into sweet stuff
sweet stuff whoa all these famous in
Sweden because there was one of the
first candies I can remember that had a
really good jingle like everyone is
different in the world everything have
their own thing but at least had Polly
in common it's chocolate butter toffee
and vanilla it smells really good I kind
of want one this is a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup chocolate on the outside
peanut butter on the inside made into a
special little cup for you to bite into
enjoy it's pretty sugary
but it tastes really good it's like what
I would want peanut butter to taste like
it's a bit too sweet
I think only peanut butter lovers in
Sweden would really like this but I
think we'll stick to our chocolate okay
so I'm gonna try Polly mm-hmm alcohol
must look like a mixture of dots and
Milk Duds which who doesn't love both of
those classics I mean yeah it's very
good it just feels like the chocolate
and European chocolate version American
chocolate is it just definitely does not
feel as you know sugary and process yeah
of this too Polly Polly I'd eat it if it
was around the office but I would
definitely go through these first to
give some backstory we actually have
this thing in Sweden called free dogs
nice like a cozy Friday and so we go to
the store and we pick up all these
Swedish Goldie's which is Swedish candy
chocolate is really really popular over
there and if it's not good we're not
gonna have it there very good I can see
any American taking down an old bag of
eating snow
both winners in my book in the u.s. you
have a water-cooler moment we have like
a fika so like after lunch you go for
coffee like we barely work into the
music of coffee on time and then usually
this is for the feed cup well this is a
rice krispy treat they just took the
cereal rice krispies and they made into
a treat by adding marshmallows to it
they have these so that when your mom
leaves you a little lunch she can write
I love you on it and so here you go oh
okay oh good
it feels very sweet finish it off for
you but I do like this I found myself
reaching to eat another one good in the
next probably one of the big staples of
Swedish candy what we like the most is
the bitter salty black licorice right
here but it comes with the fruity ones
too if you have a sweeter palate the
government are great because you have
such an opportunity to put like salt
them if you want to so like do you think
a lot of Swedish snacks are aimed at
adults and children but they're trying
to elevate a child's palate and the way
I doing it I don't know if they have any
real purpose for it I think they just
enjoy sweets to survive the winter these
are just a movie theater snacking is
just kind of like I show them on
bicycles nurse I think these little
things they're like little creatures
called nerds and you're eating them I
hated blackish head and then as I've
gotten older I've you know you just kind
of mature or whatever well I have to
agree with you too because when I was a
kid I didn't like black licorice either
mmm but now I kind of have more of a
palate for it my favorite one is the
sweet licorice one could you got one I
think you should just try it don't want
to apologize before or after its I don't
know yeah this is really good spending
your horizon I know I'm grown up I mean
it's a licorice oh there's no the worst
liquors bad word no no no it's getting
worse
nurse Lee seems like great gummies but I
just don't know why would you want all
of them in the same bag all right try it
pull out your hand okay whoa they're
very bright colors they're so tiny
that's really sweet
wow it's so much flavor oh my god it's
so good right yeah it really is actually
better than that oh my god thank you cuz
I just took a bite of something and I
don't know what it was it was a black
fish that's no I had don't do that one
I'm a nerd this is more nostalgic for me
I would kind of be more favorable to
this but I think this is kind of cool
and new cuz we don't really have
something like this in Sweden licorice
as a candy genre in general I love going
with these guys the lot okay so this
just means cars but this is like a
really well known candy throughout
Sweden you can actually find it in
almost every IKEA store - they're not
super sugary but they're very flavorful
I would say so they're kind of like
gummy marshmallows mmm that makes sense
used to dry at first mm-hmm so much I'm
candy makes sense to me now that shows
nothing to do they got two of them you
want it to be like stuck to each other
almost can I have one I really wanna
have one I'm happy because it yeah I
like my job this is very good and the
flavor is almost identical that quite
nicely
really yeah the texture is like way off
I'm gonna compare no way this is like I
mean marshmallow and this is just a
gummy and the flavor is subtle it's like
having lacroix water or something so the
biggest difference been decent Swedish
monster they're not solid enough I like
them I do like the sweet version better
they're a little bit too sweet for me
I'm apologizing ahead of time ready well
I don't have this because I think it's
weird I've never actually had this
before it's shrimp cheese I'm not sure
how are you gonna take to the fish
flavor cuz it surprises a lot of people
yeah my throat is already like yeah
stuff I would say probably had this for
afternoons we get home from school I
hold the friends I had to like that that
now this is my weakness as an American
who grew up well-versed in the snack oil
game I am addicted to our official
prepackaged cheese whatever food
scientists made that up I'm not really
like a big canned cheese girl I know
that it's a thing to take these and put
it on crackers and if you're even more
of a weird person it's a thing to just
go like ah I know that they said it's
made with real cheese don't believe it
first of all we should just never eat
anything that comes out of like I can
that will explode if you put an exit
fire whoa whoa just like kind of like
wow why we mean why it's like too cheesy
almost
believe it just a little mouse I like a
little smiley face that's a happy car I
get why you like this so much chemikal
cheese give it to me this is like paint
don't put too much fun I'm really theory
tell me when to stop
yeah try that oh my gosh alright shrimp
cheese let's go I'm on board this is
what yeah so we both love Chemical
cheese Oh cuz I know how to do that is
I'm gonna take this to be honest I would
take this this is way settled
it wasn't like overpowering anything
more like an aftertaste you can start to
taste the shrimp yeah really light yes
like hardly a flavor to it
give me 20 seconds you'll start the case
now you're gonna know yeah which is oh
yeah there it is yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]